you may remember staining slides in
biology class dipping them in red and
purple dyes to reveal microscopic
structures
[Music]
pathologists use similar techniques to
diagnose diseases like cancer
but now researchers have developed a new
type of microscope slide one that uses
nanotechnology to change the color of
cells and reveal cancers without any
staining at all
the slides called nano m slides work
using electrons embedded on their
surface that wiggle or oscillate when
they're hit with a beam of light
as light from a microscope passes
through a piece of tissue the specific
characteristics of that tissue cause the
electrons to react in different ways and
that changes the color we create a
pattern across the entire slide which
basically makes the surface into a
a type of sensor so your entire
microscope slide then becomes a sensor
and depending on what gets put on that
sensor different wavelengths of the
ambient light are absorbed
so
if
for example i put a healthy cell on on
our sensor it absorbs certain set of
wavelengths and if you take a cancer
cell and you place it on this this
sensor it will absorb a different set of
wavelengths because its composition is
slightly different
the researchers aren't entirely sure
what it is about the cancer cells that
makes them show up in different colors
it could be the density of proteins
within the cell something about the cell
skeleton or the way its contents are
organized
in this example normal cells turn yellow
and breast cancer cells turn green
and that could allow for quick accurate
diagnoses that could be vital in the
treatment of diseases like breast cancer
more and more women are being diagnosed
with really early stages of breast
cancer for example more women are
getting biopsies um to to really look do
they actually have cancer or you know an
earlier stage or a benign abnormality
in a standard cancer screen biopsy
tissue taken from the breast must be
embedded in wax sliced very thin then
placed on a slide and stained
usually a pathologist may be looking at
a subtle change in the shape of a cell
amongst a tissue of thousands or
millions of cells and you know this
nanoslide was really picking up a
difference in a cancer cell compared to
another early sort of change in these
cells by eliminating the staining step
the nano m slides produced clear and
accurate results in as little as 10
minutes
it was quite amazing that we could just
see these cancer cells
through a conventional microscope so a
normal microscope
would really distinguish these cancer
cells from from other surrounding cells
including the very cells that cancer
arises from
nano m slides probably won't be a
replacement for other diagnostic methods
but they could provide one more tool to
help pathologists standardize their
diagnosis of diseases which can
sometimes be difficult to call
we see that this this this work is
really being the tip of the iceberg
there are
other disease states and other cancers
in fact that we are
also pursuing as well
and in the meantime the researchers say
that knowing immediately whether a
tissue is cancerous or not could help
surgeons decide which sections of a
tumor to remove it's time critical you
know the patient's lying on the table
you need to get a
the the surgeon and the pathologist
wants to get a result as quickly as
possible to minimize the amount of time
that the patient is under and these
slides because of the fact that they
don't require any chemistry in terms of
the standing or labeling could have a
huge positive impact i think in that in
that setting